jet safety jamal adams
came closer to being traded than anyone
would have imagined earlier this week
and in the aftermath of
the day that ultimately resulted in no
trade for jamal adams he took to twitter
to say that any reports of me asking to
be traded from the new york jets are
completely false then he said this at
the end of the week last week i sat down
with the gm and coach gase and told them
i want to be here in new york i was told
yesterday by my agent that the gm then
went behind my back and shot me around
to teams even after i asked him to keep
me here crazy business i'll tell you
what the agent needs to be criticized
here if the truth isn't that there was a
shopping around of jamal adams i agree
teams were calling because that is a
huge difference there is it seemed to be
lost on the player yes yeah i mean i i
give you that's exactly where i wanted
to start you know i mean yeah it's all
right now we're taking jamal adam's side
of the story and i get where he could be
frustrated here but you know there is a
difference if you're an organization and
you're calling teams going hey jamal
adams is available jamal adams is
available
then you know then to the other side of
that where teams are going hey is there
anybody on your team hey is jamal adams
maybe can we can we get him is there is
there a price and there's a difference
there because then you know uh douglas
the gm of the the jets just sits there
and goes well
you know no he's not really available
but what are you willing to offer and
there's a totally different a totally
big difference between you know one and
the other there is what i'm trying to
say as i mumble through my words there
and joe douglas himself the jets gm was
on espn radio in new york and he
responded to this tweet from jamal adams
accusing him of actively shopping the
jets safety here's joe douglas
we have not we did not make any calls on
jamal teams called us and so
uh teams had been calling us um
ever since
you know there was a social media issue
a few weeks back my message was clear
that jamal was an absolute stud and
we're not interested in moving in teams
continue to call you know i was always
taught where i'm from if team calls you
listen to what they have to say at the
end of the day teams called on a lot of
a lot of our players
and at the end of the day today we felt
like
the value that was offered for any
player didn't meet or exceed the value
that we have for that player as a new
york jet
you know that's the absolute truth but
it does give you an idea chris and i
said this earlier on the radio side that
these players really are just
commodities do you have a guy on your
roster and we love this guy and he's
fine until you offer us enough that it
justifies surrendering the contract and
saying farewell forever to the player
and and that's the way it goes but for
the jets the analysis was simple no one
offered enough to get them to say okay
we will trade jamal adams but as joe
douglas tells it
the jets weren't actively shopping jamal
adams and the the social media issue he
referred to that was in the aftermath of
the week two monday night game against
the browns remember adams got benched at
one point during the game right he went
to instagram and he removed all
references to the jets from his social
media page and that sparked some ideas
that maybe he wanted out and that would
be the opening if you're interested in
jamal adams to call the jets and say hey
if this guy wants out and you want to
you want to make that happen
here's what we're willing to do so i can
understand why when you combine that
with the fact that jets aren't very good
so they would be sellers at the trade
deadline that's how we get to this point
it doesn't mean the jets were trying to
unload jamal adams exactly right
for all of us out there and even teams
yeah it you know jamal adams is he's an
intense emotional young football player
who's you know maybe
said some things on radio and twitter
that maybe he shouldn't have and i i
think that is yeah the perception of him
i think through the league was oh maybe
he's not happy with the jets maybe he
wants to get out of there uh but uh
certainly you know joe douglas adam gase
the one thing i'll say about both of
those guys and i i know adam i don't
know joe douglas all that well but know
a lot of people that know him and the
one thing you know about adam and really
anybody that's around him in coach gates
is just the fact that they're not bsers
i mean they lay it on the line i mean we
just saw earlier in you know in one of
our pods adam gates saying hey the
results are what they are right now
we're not good and i'm not doing a good
job because we only have one win you
know he'll take it on the chin like a
true champ and yeah i can't fault them
for just at least listening to offers
and things like that now you got to blow
them out of the water because jamal
adams is i you could argue jamal adam's
the best safety in football he's
certainly in that conversation uh but
but yeah they took some calls they
listened to what people have to say and
maybe if the team offered them two
first-round picks or something like that
maybe they would have done it but that
was not offered and uh for that they
keep keep the safety who who will be a
superstar uh for a long long time here
in new york
cowboys reportedly offered a first round
pick and an early third day pick a
fourth or a fifth rounder for adams the
jets rejected that and the ravens
reportedly were in contact and actively
proceed pursuing jamal adams and there's
a thought that maybe after the season
the ravens will try again and you can
keep trying all you want until you offer
the jets enough to get them to say we'll
do it they're not going to do it and and
you know why would you trade jamal adams
well again if you can get a great haul
of draft picks in return and you decide
it's fair value then you do it and and
also chris there's just been enough
flash points from jamal adams over the
past few years remember it seemed like
todd bowles had to talk to him every
other week right in 2018 and adam gase
has gotten that part of it under control
it doesn't seem like jamal adams is
saying things that are unfortunate
problematic for the team but nobody
knows him better than the jets and the
mere fact that they would even have
those conversations and entertain those
offers it tells you that at some point
they they recognize maybe he's not
somebody who needs to be with this
franchise over the long haul maybe he's
not a guy to build around because of the
fact that he is a little temperamental
that he does you know we played at the
very top of the tv segment as the hour
began le'veon bell talking about how the
jets are a work in progress and it's
going to take time you know jamal adams
was basically despondent after they lost
to the jaguars on sunday and and maybe
they're maybe they're thinking look he's
a great player but the culture we're
trying to build isn't somebody who's
going to have highs that are too high
and lows that are too low but somebody
who's more even keeled and understands
that this really is a process i'm just
trying to yeah to process why they would
even entertain these discussions and it
may be at some level they were kind of
hoping they would be made an offer they
can't refuse well maybe you know yeah
you know we don't know that uh either
way they're listening to it i mean
you're right about jamal adams i do
think he's got to dial back you know
some of the emotional outbursts i love
watching him play uh i think he's a
great dude he's got great energy
i've been around him a few times and i
mean you could see how uh he's the
perfect guy to be uh safety a strong
safety in the nfl yeah he i mean even
when you're just around him in a normal
everyday setting he's intense and you
could tell he loves football but yeah
he's got to worry about maybe crossing
that line too much to where it becomes
yeah a little bit of the hot the highs
are too high the lows are too low to
where it affects the locker room i don't
think the jets ultimately wanted to
trade him the jets don't have that many
good players and you could argue he's
maybe the best player on the team and if
you want to rebuild you'd like to keep
those guys around especially when
they're very young still like adams is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports